we're genius meets possibility ever
leave the house and then wonder if you
left the iron steaming the tea kettle
boiling or the lights burning who hasn't
okay bye you know I would love to be
able to check on my place no matter
where I happen to be it turns out there
may soon be an app for that Carnegie
Mellon engineer Anthony row is testing
the notion with help of the National
Science Foundation the appliances in his
apartment are all plugged into a sensor
he designed the consents how much energy
of the appliance is using and it can
also allow you to remotely turn the
appliance on knock sensors transmitted
via Wi-Fi and he can check in on any
connected computer or smartphone and the
software can help him save energy and
give scatterbrains like me some peace of
mind now where did I put my phone I'm
Miles O'Brien